[Musique]
annick girardin ministre d outre mer
découvre mascarin et son jardin
botanique sa visite sur cet espace
permet d'appréhender la question de la
préservation de la biodiversité à la
réunion elle est accueillie à son
arrivée par le conseil départemental des
jeunes située sur l'île de la réunion
qui se place au sud de la rose des vents
ce jardin est une ode aux spécificités
locales à sa diversité culturelle avec
928 espèces végétales indigènes dont 246
endémique
la réunion est un sanctuaire de la
biodiversité l'émission de connaissances
et de préservation porté par le jardin
botanique sont également présenté à la
délégation
c'est important que à chaque fois on
puisse allier culture patrimoine
histoire développement économique
éducation bien sûr et qu'on puisse grâce
à cela a montré ce que la réunion et
surtout faire que la réunion de demain
elle est véritablement fait mis en avant
l'ensemble de ses richesses dans un
développement durable tels que vous
faites aujourd'hui la ministre d outre
mer a également symboliquement planté
une rose de bourbon la nouvelle roseraie
du jardin l'areuse bourbon un patrimoine
végétal de la réunion qui fête cette
année ses 200 ans
il ya comme ça une synergie qui se met
en place autour du développement de
notre patrimoine naturel qui est
concrétisée ici au jardin des mascaras
donc ça a été vraiment un échange qu'on
à a fait avec la ministre et l'ensemble
des acteurs qui a été très riche est
vraiment elle a été très à l'écouté et
elle pense même accompagner tous les
acteurs autour de ce projet de
développement durable et de ce projet de
conservation de notre patrimoine naturel
qui est vraiment est un patrimoine très
riche
annick jardin rencontre également
pendant son séjour à la réunion les
acteurs de l'armée flore l'association
réunionnaise pour la modernisation de
l'économie fruitière légumière et
horticole la recherche et l'innovation
agricole sont au coeur des
au niveau département on a mis en place
différents outils
si je reviens chez les surfaces
agricoles nous avons mis en place un
plan pour inciter les propriétaires à
vendre ou à louer la surface en cas de
vente ses 3000 euros l'hectare en cas de
location et ses 1500 euros l'hectare de
façon à préserver les surfaces agricoles
et des façons puisque quand un art
culture part à la retraite
ben c'est c'était à ne reste pas à
l'abandon
[Musique]